the pillars that we established in
Arkham Asylum really have stayed
something that we've we've developed and
evolved throughout all three games but
for us we really wanted to take big
risks at every new iteration so in
Arkham City it was this massive new
open-world structure but for Batman
Arkham Knight it's really all about the
Batmobile delivering that the experience
and the promise of driving this
legendary car in this legendary City
adding the Batmobile was something that
we were very conscious of that it didn't
just feel like it was a bolted on
driving section we didn't want to just
throw away everything that we had
developed for previous games because
Batman is is about using whatever is the
most effective tool at a time so the
idea of man and machine really lay at
the heart of that using the Batmobile
when it's appropriate but also using the
abilities of the Batmobile to augment
Batman himself so you would have seen in
the demo being able to eject out of the
Batmobile to gain insane altitude and
then dive down through the streets of
Gotham above so the integration of
Batman and the Batmobile really lay at
the core of the design of Arkham 9
working on next-gen hardware it's easy
to think we're just going to go insane
with everything but we had to make very
specific decisions about what we went
insane with and the Batmobile is insane
I mean its massive its destructive its
powerful it's fast it does all of these
incredible things that are very very
exciting and very very fresher than you
but building out the entirety of Gotham
City itself was something else we just
could not have done on previous
generations of hardware so there were
the two massive features that next-gen
enabled for us the arkham knight is a a
brand new character in Batman's universe
and we've it's been a real honor to be
able to design a completely original
character in collaboration with DC
there's a lot more information about the
arkham knight that we're going to talk
about down the track but is a very
significant character and someone who
can really step up and step to Batman
which is something that's very rare for
that man to be able to meet someone who
is incredibly powerful and can get the
jump on him as you would have seen at
the end of the demo
batman arkham knight coming later this
year on PlayStation 4 Xbox one and PC